hey what's up my name is Samuel leaves
welcome to this week's Q&A Sunday so
every single week on a Sunday at 7 p.m.
I like to sit through some of the
questions that you've had
property-related
and do my very best to answer them and
I'm going to answer some right now from
last week's Q&A Sunday if while I'm
speaking if you get questions pop up in
your head
comment below and I'll do my best to
answer every single one if possible
also if a question is really specific
that's good the more specific the better
so just get commenting right below and
if you like the answers as well don't
forget to smash a like button on the
video right let's get right into this
and see what we can find
Annabelle says Samuel regarding council
tax in the HMO who's responsible for
paying the council tax the landlord all
the tenants also do you pay council tax
for each room or for the whole property
great question so typically the landlord
will pay the council tax in an HMO part
of the attractiveness for HMOs is that
all the bills are included so it's
expected that a landlord will pay in
regards to do you have to pay count
sites for each room or for the whole
property normally you just pay one
council tax for the whole property
unless the council deems the the rooms
to be almost like self-contained so if
it's like a studio with a kitchenette
and an ensuite then you might finally
have to pay council tax for each
individual room but if it's just a
bedroom of an ensuite normally you will
just pay council sites for the whole
house but do check with the council
before you buy it so there's no nasty
surprises I hope that helps what else we
got Leon says hi Samuel how do you
manage a serviced accommodation that's
not near where you live eg preparing the
guests after previous guest leaves
cleaners etc okay a lot of my serviced
accommodations are far away I would just
say get a good team and yes you do not
have to do it yourself the real trick to
serviced accommodation is having a good
channel manager so all the bookings are
taken care of I use a company called a
VEVO that's Evi Ivo and then also having
a really good cleaner not just someone
who cleans but someone who really
understands the business model someone
that can you know come in and make the
beds and make sure it's all nice I can't
recommend recommend my cleaner because
you have to find someone that's close to
the property and it depends on where you
buy so it can 100% be passive and
hands-off however I might suggest in the
early days getting involve
because if you're involved in doing it
yourself there's a lot of learning in
that and it's never about earlier to get
learning but the helps what else we got
Fran says how do I find landlords and
just talk to them without agents I know
I can find them on gumtree or if a book
is viewing with the agency do I ask if
the landlord can also be there asking if
the landlord can also be there is a bit
weird you know hey can I not be there
too it's the agent will just not
understand why go on to sites where
landlords advertise their rooms for rent
or their properties for sale and they do
it without an agent so places like open
rent you can go to spare room you can go
obviously on gumtree as you said
Craigslist or you can book a viewing
with with an agent but book it in the
evening and then what you'll find is
usually the estate agent doesn't want to
go so they'll just ask the owner of the
property to do it and then you've got
the owner of all to yourself to talk
about whatever you want to talk about
but what I would say as well is good
networking if you go to networking
events probably networking events you're
me so many landlords and be able to
build relationships that way so there's
a whole ton of ways but what I would say
as well is there's nothing wrong with
agents you can get good deals from
agents direct as well so just bear that
in mind - Tim Sandom thank you once
again for your time is it best to start
with BRR or would it be better to play
it safe with a standard by - layer or
maybe just a three bed Terrace -
conversion to form an HMO I'm going to
the crash course so maybe when I'm there
I'll know just can't wait to get stuck
into my property journey there's no
right answer for this there's so many
strategies and I would never say that
one particular strategy is better than
another particular strategy it all
depends on what you want to get out of
it
do you want to build wealth do you want
to build quick cash flow have you got
funds if you've got no funds but going
on the crash course is definitely a
smart move and I think that we'll be
able to help okay Hannah day I went to
the crash course in October the fourth
boom wild on her and we'll see you on
the deal finding extravaganza in
November awesome I'm finding my patch
would it be sensible to focus on finding
properties to convert to HMOs just
outside of article for area in
Birmingham before the restriction
increases even though Birmingham is
peaking or is that crazy return on
investment wise and should I be focusing
on places that have bottomed out thanks
for the amazing contact Hannah Hannah
I'm personally buying in Birmingham
right now
bringing article four I think you
probably know this if you just came from
a crash course and bringing an article
four into Birmingham in June next year
so if you can buy houses and convert
them into HMOs that are going to be
article four in that area that's a very
very smart move also hi Gemma's work
really well in Birmingham because
there's so much demand for tenants so
even though you're not buying in an area
that's bottomed out like in Liverpool
for instance you're still going to see
capital appreciation in my opinion in
Birmingham over the next year or two and
you're also going to get really good
wins so as long as the ROI is good I
think buying and getting grandfather
rights and taking advantage of the
article four situation in Birmingham is
a really smart move so I think you're on
the right track but I look forward to
seeing you next month at the deal
finding extravaganza okay Lord
arash you've got Lords asking questions
isn't that fantastic
what does refinance cash out mean I
always hear in your videos okay we
financing cash out means when your
property goes up in value rather than
selling the house and then and then and
then benefiting from the capital gains
that's probably not that smart because
you've got to pay tax on that money
so what smart people do is when a
property goes up in value is they then
take that money out as a loan they
borrow against that property that's
called refinance in the house and then
that lonely he pays zero tax on and you
can reinvest that into more properties
that's what I mean when I say putting
your cash out of a property Joshua
Wow there's a lot of questions here I'm
gonna do a few more do as many as I can
do I hope you guys have enjoyed this if
you're doing the videos smash like again
don't forget if you've got questions
offshoot questions that come as with all
these we don't quite understand
something comment below as well
Joshua says I'm 16 years old I'm very
interested in this I'm wondering what
type of things I could do to get
involved in property investing leaving
school is not an option as its
compulsory until I'm 18 years old to be
honest I do not enjoy it and I feel like
it's a waste of time just sure what I'd
probably agree with you probably is a
waste of time because people teach you
go to school to get good exams to then
get a job then to get money well why not
just figure out how to get money and cut
all the other stuff so you probably
write if you've got a stay at school
till you're 18 if it's compulsory
then what I would say is just educate
yourself and start getting in the right
circles and even building your portfolio
alongside school I mean that's what I
say a lot of people do this alongside a
job so just do it
cool but look into it because I'm pretty
sure you can leave school at 16
maybe they change the rules but if you
can get out and I don't advise that for
everybody I advise that for people that
don't need the qualification to go and
do their dream job if you don't need the
qualification to go into your dream job
then it's probably is a waste of time
okay Kristina boss I love Kristina boss
she's always on YouTube commenting
you're awesome hi Sam you know if you
have a house like residential and have a
spare room can you rent out the spare
room like serviced accommodation without
breaking the law thank you appreciate
your work yes you can you can rent out
the room as long as it's not against
your mortgage terms you can and the good
news is it's tax-free opportunity I
think it's like nine thousand pounds a
year it's completely tax-free to rent
out a spare room in your house so yeah
that's a really legitimate smart thing
to do so good thinking Kristina just
check that what your mortgage terms are
and then it's all okay with the house
that you've got but smart move
knocking boxing what happened to that
story of sad you bought a property with
your money
no video released since then it's going
really well sadly it's absolutely
smashing it and there's gonna be a video
coming soon on that hopefully if I get
time Ben Bentley how do you find
investors at networking events tell the
world that you're looking for investors
so go to a networking event and if you
have an opportunity to stand up and
rather than saying all I'm looking for
investors come and speak to me if you're
an investor and making it all about me
me me I'm gonna I'm gonna give them
value so I'm going to say hey I've got a
really good deal I've just secured on
viewing some houses next week if you're
an investor and you're interest in
having a chat come and speak to me so
always offer value first serve before
you sell okay because Casal says I'd
like to know how you make money in
property in different ways of making
money through property
additionally thank you for blowing the
videos okay thank you how do I make any
property in many ways I make money from
renting houses out I make money from
buying them below market value
I lent money from the capital
appreciation of the house I meant money
by turning one property into multiple
properties and then selling off the
units I make money in property by
packaging and selling deals or I don't
really do that anymore it's something
that I used to do a lot of my students
do that I make money in property by
teaching other people how to make money
in property I make money in property by
I've had a letting agency that there's
so
ways to make money in property it's the
thing is if you look on the so no times
rich list most people on the Sunday
Times Rich List invest in property if
they Volvo become rich by investing in
property or they've become rich from
business and they invest their profits
now into property so learning how to
understand property market and how to
make money in property is a really good
skill and I reckon as an entrepreneur
sometimes people say to me Samuel why do
you teach property if you make so much
money in property well number one is
because I absolutely love it and I do
for free I do do it for free as well but
number two is because I'm an
entrepreneur so I'll make money in all
different avenues of property because
I'm an entrepreneur that's what
entrepreneurs do they find a gap and
then they fill the gap and then they
head there's a fair exchange which is if
you're adding value the money follows
Albert Einstein says don't try and be
successful trying to be valuable and
then a success will follow so that's
just some ways I'm sure you can think of
more ways but there's a few ok Leon what
are some of the different ways to
structure a basic joint venture Leon a
joint venture agreement is a blank piece
of paper again it's just a case of
coming together with what is a win-win
whenever you're doing the joint ventures
you always have equal risk and equal
reward so what are they putting in what
are you put it in they might put the
money in you might put the deal in and
the skills so just work out really clear
what you're going to be bringing to the
table have an exit strategy write it
down in plain English and then give it
to a solicitor that specializes in
drawing up joint ventures and they'll be
able to tell if you've missed anything
if there's any blind spots they'll be
able to legally for you that's the basic
summary of joint ventures ok what do you
think of the future of article 4 I think
article 4 is going to be all over the
country and I think HMOs are going to be
something which is like wasn't it great
when you could buy a house and turn it
into HMO without planning permission and
people are going to kick themselves is
my conclusion ok we're gonna do one more
question let's see what we've got Mandy
Howard my parents have recently passed
away sorry to hear that and have left me
60,000 pounds I'm 56 years old and would
love to retire and spend time with my
grandchildren fantastic good for you I'm
thinking of investing in HMOs but don't
know where to start are all of
Manchester and Salford are are to go for
what do you recommend what I recommend
is just figuring out how much money
you need and working backwards so you
say you want to be able to retire and
spend time with your grandkids what I
work out is how much money do you need
per month to be able to live on for the
rest of your life and retire if that's
two thousand pounds or three thousand
pound whatever that is figure out what
that is and then work backwards HMOs are
a really good strategy for sure I don't
know Manchester super well so but but
just work backwards always get the end
goal in mind but 60,000 pounds I'd
probably do some 60,000 pounds if I want
to retire you I'd be definitely looking
at how I can recycle that money so how
can you put the money in add value and
then pull the money out and win some
repeat that would be my strategy buy
refurbish refinance some fantastic
questions thank you so much for those
also don't forget to comment your
questions below I'm gonna be the exact
same thing next week I'd love to answer
your questions
also don't forget I think sometimes we
can overthink things just a little bit
and we can come up with so many
questions and not take action so if
you've not seen the financial freedom
challenge that's where I start all over
again with nothing and become
financially free in one week and I've
done this many times it's just watching
that the inspiration of how you can
actually do this fast and get faster
results the videos right here also I'd
suggest that you come down to a property
investors crash course where you'll
really get a kick up the bump to start
taking some serious action if you've not
been to the crash course it will blow
you away you can get free tickets right
here and of course don't forget to
subscribe right here thanks so much for
watching I'll see you next week